[Music]
there's no slow in the Big Bang it's a
little different for the folks at Murphy
Brown they took a 20-year break I've
been waiting that that's what they're
back this fall i sat down with Candice
Bergen and her growing up TV son Jake
McDorman and they made it clear this
show was coming back with a bang action
Murphy is not a timid show and we're
certainly not starting out it timidly
that's for sure
Avery has become a television journalist
like his mother and then our first
episode we are both on television
programs that are trying to outdo each
other on ratings he finds a very
different home for his journalism
they've shot one episode of their 13
show order so far and right out of the
gate Murphy Brown goes head-to-head with
her son who works for a conservative
Network so yeah this cast isn't pulling
any political punches the second episode
deals with the White House briefing room
will it be the current White House
briefing room oh you heard of it we'll
see some of those folks the episode is
called I and then there's a heart with a
line through it Huckabee and just like
the original series expect to see some
famous guest stars I hear the first
episode that there's a big guest yeah
I'm just gonna say a name just for fun
Hillary Clinton okay is there anyone out
there that is your ultimate get to be on
this for me Barack Obama it could happen
[Applause]
you
[Applause]